de cette boîte qui chante les sardines
changé sa vie
ok merci la foule on n'est pas bien y'a
des fous allez vous savez quoi
sortez tous plus vous fatiguer
sortez sortez motards en sort tout le
monde en sort tout le monde en sort tout
le monde c'est comme ça c'est ça c'est
ça
allez sortez toutes sortes et je suis
sorti et sortez sortez allez sortez tous
à laisser comme ça allait qu'est-ce
qu'il a sonné comme ça mais sortez
sortez zine portal
merci voilà voilà
c'est bien une émission comme ça c'est
bien lui arriver là les i on est avec
audrey dana pascal elbé qu'il fait on
s'éclate si le ca les unes sortez sortez
sortez sortez sortez les gens vont
vraiment croire que c'est nous qui avons
fait fuir et alors je vais vous dire
merci vous êtes sur des 8 ou les
versions en direct
on est en train de sortir tout le monde
merci merci nous sommes dans une
situation
voilà où les classes et si on se disait
tous voir bonsoir audrey on soir pascal
elbé bon par contre vous pouvez sortir
sera rien et je regarde quand vous êtes
à la merci
alors nous sommes bien sûr sur des
bidons touche pas à mon poste merci
d'être avec nous comment ça va pascal
elbé audrey dana
ah je me sentais bien fava les verts
force d'âme ça va ça y est quoi sur
pouvoir ouvrir en défiance étudier la
lumière les gars là alors et non mais
rome était la lumière l'eau égales à
payer quand même on a fêté ses noces qui
a des gars qui passe devant la caméra et
tout c'est le bordel pas plus alors
quand ça va vous c'est quoi votre
émission préférée audrey cetus pas mon
pass bercy ça me fait plaisir que les
six démissions pas maintenant mais j'ai
pas la télé au jeu des coûts les
émissions plateau et j'adore à balard je
peux vous dire un truc là on est dans le
top 3 c'est vrai que toutes les
émissions que j'ai fait clasher au top
la vieille tout le monde comme salaire
adoré mais je demande juste on respire
j'aimerais jeune cyril hanouna juge à
roland garros sur une balle litigieuse
aller le public aime tout le monde sort
et tout